I worked for child support department in my early 20s.
That was enough for me to realize
I had to always be financially independent
and never solely on a man.
It was scary seeing women struggle.
Not my words. Read the comment.
Seems like a few people didn't like the delivery last time,
so I'll say it. Nice and soft and calm.
It is a tale as old as time that a woman is dependent on a man,
and then at some point in her life,
she gets left.
Whether that's because he cheated on her with the secretary,
he found a younger model, he moved on with someone else,
or she woke up and realized, fuck,
I don't like this. This is miserable.
I can't live like this anymore.
Something's gonna happen. Maybe he dies,
but something's gonna happen
where you're probably not gonna be in this relationship anymore.
And to have put all of your financial eggs in the basket of one person
is not smart. Whether you're listening to women who are telling you
as one of the ex wives, this is a bad idea,
or you're listening to the children saying,
my mom had to go through. Blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah.
Or people that worked for child support and other agencies that are,
you know, surrounding this.
This type of situation,
everybody will say, oh, yeah,
when you really look at it,
look down into the nitty gritty of it,
yeah, no,
it's not. It's It.
That's not a good idea. It's definitely not a good idea.
So just. If it sounds too good to be true.
It. It is.
It is. It is. I promise it is.